our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
while many concert halls remain closed
because of the pandemic one pianist is
bringing music into the world hunter
noack is transforming the classical
concert experience starting with the
perfect backdrop since we first told you
about the oregon native his concerts
have expanded across the northwest and
even to new york jan crawford shows us
how music in the great outdoors is even
more timely in the era of covid
[Music]
it's a place of spectacular beauty
the cliffs and tall trees of northern
oregon
and then
the unexpected
floating through the air the elegant
melody of classical music
my mom and i were saying wouldn't it be
cool if if you could just have a piano
and go anywhere
so that's what hunter nowak did
traveling across the pacific northwest
introducing classical music to new
audiences in some wild places
[Music]
i could do a show pretty much
every day
and be happy he tows his piano all over
this state on a flatbed trailer it's
really kind of an audacious thing that
you're doing do people go what
yeah i what are you doing yeah
it's really impressive to have a
nine-foot steinway
being hauled around with the pickup
truck
with the help of a few friends
the flatbed becomes a stage i wanted the
same piano that's in carnegie hall and
that's in all of the majors and this is
the same instrument and in a way i feel
like it it fits because then these are
our halls the columbia gorge is our
cathedral and the alvar desert is our
church
[Music]
on this night it's on a cliff jetting
into the columbia river does it seem
different playing here
it does i mean there are more
distractions but wind wind of course but
you know i love to just
be able to close my eyes or between
pieces take a breath in
fresh air i think it affects how i play
nowak performs in the landscape spaces
with astounding natural beauty and rich
history you're taking this like
beautiful music to places where
people would not have access to us yeah
you know we have the people that come
from portland and eugene that are
classical music lovers that get to
explore these parts of the state that
they otherwise might not and then we
have people that are coming to these
places that are familiar to them
places they go fishing places they go
camping it gives people sort of a
different lens through which to see this
land that they
know and love
he makes the surroundings part of the
performance this land is owned by the
native american warm springs tribe
and joining noak here is james edmond
greeley
in this reimagined concert hall nowac
hopes to remove the normal barriers to
classical music
there are free tickets casual clothes
and the opposite of formal seating like
perching on a rock overlooking the stage
a third of his audience has never
attended a classical music concert but
even those who have likely haven't done
it like this wearing wireless headphones
to encourage wandering
with the music in your headphones the
music becomes a soundtrack to your
experience in the landscape nowak is
winning over the classical skeptics i
said to my friend if she had invited me
to a classical music concert i would
have said
but this was tremendous and the outdoor
averse well she was a little bit
hesitant at first but she likes
classical music so i am speechless very
speechless there was nothing artificial
here it was all natural natural
surroundings yes indeed
it's a new community nowak hopes to
create each night
out on the edge
of nowhere what do you hope they get out
of it i hope that
they find
little moments of magic
it's those little moments that draw
people's emotions that like give them
space to feel something and to notice
the beauty
around us and even for an hour
wander
wherever they want is something totally
worth doing and they're
finding that magical moment
with people that they may think they
have nothing in common with absolutely
[Music]
wow i love the lady natural surroundings
yes indeed i've never been to oregon but
it sure makes me want to go i just i
love the whole idea i love the idea with
the headphones so you can wander around
and take it all in i know i don't want
to listen to music 100 come to new york
before please come again yes hey did you
notice that he had a carpet on some of
the and some of the outdoor settings
that he brought up but i was very classy
i just love the way he travels on the
flatbed truck i don't know who picked up
the piano to roll the carpet out but
nice got it done nice very nice piece